un qui a trouvé non pas une école qui
ferme ses portes comme cela arrivait
trop souvent jusqu alors mais un
établissement qui renaît et quand une
école rouvre ses lui lâche tout entier
qui se trouve irrigué d'un sang nouveau
ce village revit grâce à son école jax
dans la montagne de haute-loire commencé
à mourir comme tous ces coins isolés où
les jeunes ne veulent plus rester
beaucoup de vaches mais plus que 123
habitants et une école fermée depuis dix
ans voilà qu'en février dernier les
habitants gros sites d'une nouvelle
famille de trois enfants en ont assez du
silence de l'école et surtout d'envoyer
leurs enfants au bourg voisin par le car
de ramassage pendant l'hiver qui n'en
finit pas quatre mois de neige
d'habitude pétition unanime des chefs de
famille et puis victoire inattendue en
juin l'inspection académique du puy
annonce la réouverture officielle pour
le 10 septembre du fait des huit à dix
élèves annoncé alors les enfants
prennent l'eponge les maires les
pinceaux les pères l'appel et la pioche
jusqu'au mère qui s'occupe du ballet
bref tout le monde se retrouve pour
remettre en état l'unique salle de
classe sous les yeux du doyen du village
j'ai bien content moi c'est très bien ça
va apporter pas mal de vie dans une
agence du mois
et voici les nouveaux arrivés ils ont
permis au village d'atteindre le chiffre
de la réouverture en zone de montagne
huit élèves satisfaction toute
particulière dans cette famille
d'éleveurs dont les deux petites filles
partait tôt et revenez tard christine et
maryline sont allés à l'école un chemin
d'accès fayette pendant des années et
maintenant elles vont pouvoir aller à
l'école sur place c'est pas trop tôt
tout de même et ben oui parce que ils
pourront prendre leur repas à la maison
et j'ai toujours à pour le village pour
leur rentrée hier matin sur le perron de
l'école la plus émue c'était la
maîtresse en tablier rouge
elle arrive du d'école qui a fermé le 30
juin ces jours là tous les parents
s'étaient rassemblés pour dire adieu à
l'école et nous étions tous assez
tristes parce qu'une école c'est un
petit peu le coeur d'un village tandis
que ici l'école vient d'ouvrir et
j'étais très heureuse d'y venir d'abord
parce que c'est un petit peu les
origines de ma famille qui sont ici on
va de nouveau entendre des cris
d'enfants dans la cour on va on va de
nouveau les voir passer le matin et est
repassé à midi dans les rues
alors les grands projets des grandes
tables les titille la réouverture d'une
école ne suffit pas à faire revivre
pleinement une montagne déserté mais il
y contribue
peut-on dire alors que jax revit et pour
longtemps
en tout cas ce sourire encore timide
nous incite à le croire